[Musique]
joseph peraste bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le maire sortant du marigot vous avez 60
il 68 ans pardon vous êtes retraité de
l'éducation nationale vous êtes candidat
à votre propre succession vous allez
conduire la liste pour un marigot fort
et solidaire pourquoi monsieur peraste
vous vous représentez qu'est ce qui vous
motive encore alors je crois que c'est
très très simple et tout le monde le
comprendra donc je crois avoir fait une
mandature clôturée par un bilan qui me
paraît positif je me dis bon et bien
pour une bonne gestion pour un bon
développement de la ville du marigot un
mandat ne devrait pas suffire il faut
que j'aille pour un deuxième mandat pour
vraiment terminer ce que j'avais
commencé puisque tous nous savons quand
une mandature les difficultés de montage
de dossier pour obtenir les financements
et tout et tout rassembler font que une
mandature ne peut suffire maintenant je
me dis les maillotins devons comprendre
qu'il faut permettre à l'équipe en place
de poursuivre
et comme ça nous aurons vraiment une
ville où le bien-être sera assurée alors
vous aurez face à vous entre autres
daniel gros désir qui était votre
quatrième adjoint si je ne me trompe et
qui a démissionné il vous accuse de ne
pas avoir tenu les promesses de campagne
mais surtout de gérer seul la mairie
sans écouter les membres de votre équipe
bon daniel bour désir chez jusqu'à ce
jour un ami qui m'étonne d'ailleurs dans
son évolution puisque il a attendu six
ans pour quitter le conseil municipal
puisqu'il était 4e adjoint en charge de
la vie associative attendre six ans en
gros deux mois avant la fin d'octobre
deux ou trois mois avant la fin de la
mandature abandonné le bateau je reste
persuadé que ce sont plus ces objectifs
se sont plus ses projets personnels qui
devait l'intéressé et j'accepte qu'il
soit en face et que nous ayons a discuté
pendant la campagne il dit aussi que
vous avez supprimé 40 mille euros de la
subvention
à louer ou aux associations c'est vrai
pas c'est en partie vrai dans la mesure
où il dit que c'est moi qui ai supprimé
non c'est lui et le conseil municipal
puisque quand un maire prend une
décision c'est une décision votée par un
conseil municipal votée même par une
majorité et la majorité chez moi cvt
d'une personne y compris monsieur désir
qui ne sait jamais même pas abstenus
voire même s'opposer
alors il a dit que vous êtes passé après
et que vous avez supprimé ses 30000
euros ce qui voudrait dire monsieur
qu'au conseil municipal je n'ai que des
idéaux des imbéciles dans la mesure où
si après le maire point une décision
unilatérale
je crois qu'il y à vraiment problème
dans ce conseil municipal
ce n'est pas le cas alors vous disais
que c'est quand même vrai ça veut dire
que vous avez quand même supprimé 40000
euros à 6 ainsi pourquoi
et bien voilà c'est très simple c'est
d'abord pas moi le conseil municipal
nous avions pris des dispositions par
rapport à des difficultés financières de
la ville puisque vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir que pratiquement toutes les
villes toutes les communes de la
martinique souffre de désengagement de
l'état donc y compris le marigot qui
soit une petite commune et nous avons
décidé c'est vrai en 2018 de se dire que
bon d'ailleurs en cette année nous
n'avions pas fait non plus la fête
patronale il a fait de dominer et aussi
des mesures restrictive vis-à-vis des
associations par contre nous avons
augmenté notre aide
vis-à-vis de ces mêmes associations par
le biais de prêts de deux chaises de
tables mises à disposition de salles et
tout service qui nous serait demandée
par les associations
alors quels sont les grands axes de
votre programme
votre votre deuxième si vous êtes élu
peur 2020 alors les contacts tourne
autour d'un de tout petits mots que nous
avons mis en début de notre mandature en
assurer le bien-être de la population du
marigot qu'est-ce que celui voilà qu'est
ce que ça veut dire simplement qu'il
fait que au nom se prononce sur le
développement économique que l'on se
prononce ou les développements
touristiques que l'on se développe sur
le développement de la culture que l'on
s'applique
n'est ce pas à répondre aux aspirations
de la population
car cette population du mal à beaucoup
souffert et elle a besoin de bien être
elle a souffert à cause de quoi on se
souvient des sargasses mais l'assouvir à
cause de quoi
mais à bien avant le jardin sel a
souffert d'une gestion de 20 ans quand
même maintenant je ne serais pas là pour
tout développer aujourd'hui puisque je
n'ai que cinq minutes
mais si elle a décidé comme cela en 2014
de changer de gouvernance
si elle a décidé de changer une équipe
qui était là depuis 19 ans je pense
c'est parce qu'elle était en souffrance
et qu'elle a voulu se faire en tant que
vous allez retrouver effectivement
nouvelle fois l'ancien maire ange
lavenaire que vous avez battu en 2014
à force de vous croiser avec monsieur
l'avenir vous allez devenir amis ah non
mais nous sommes toujours amis entre
nous marie boutin si on n'est pas amis
on est parent ce n'est peut-être pas le
cas pour monsieur l'amener à mais je dis
simplement qu'il étonne dans la mesure
où beaucoup beaucoup se posent la
question mais qu'est ce qu'il vient
faire
joseph peraste je vous remercie
[Musique]